[Music]
good afternoon my name is bill bill ado
and I'm a developer advocate at Google
so today we're going to talk about
improving game performance so that you
can make high fidelity games on Android
the first part will be about common
performance issues and the profiling
tools you can use to find them next
jung-woo will be talk from Samsung we'll
be talking about optimization techniques
and then finally we'll hear from duke at
netmarble about how those techniques
were put into practice in one of their
games lineage 2
what are the best reasons for making a
high-performance game is to have high
fidelity when we say high fidelity we
mean high quality realistic immersive
graphics high fidelity games used to be
limited to just PCs and consoles but
with recent improvements in hardware
it's now possible to play these types of
games on mobile devices even with the
latest hardware developers still need to
be aware of performance issues before I
talk about that I want to discuss some
of the basic concepts of rendering
rendering commands are built on the CPU
the graphics driver accused these
commands for the GPU to render because
the GPU is a separate processor it runs
asynchronously with the CPU this means
that the CPU can build commands for the
current frame while the GPU renders
commands from the previous frame to
avoid artifacts frames are displayed at
vsync intervals this is every sixteen
point six seven milliseconds if the GPU
is if the GPU misses a vsync the frame
buffer is displayed at the next we think
too many missed vsync can cause
stuttering or Jencks if the frame is not
a multiple of you sinks you can see
uneven frame times so for example let's
say we have a frame time that's about 20
milliseconds it will deplete it will
display some of the frames every 2v
sinks and some frames every every vsync
to smooth about the frame rate we can
delay the rendering to make the frame
time and even vsync of intervals as in
this case will now see the display
happening every other vsync
one of the advantages of doing this is
also that it saves battery life because
you're doing less work on the CPU and
GPU the trade-off of course is that
you're doing less render so let's look
at some of the issues that can cause
slow performance CPU activity can be the
cause of slow performance a CPU
bottleneck is when a CPU can't keep up
with the GPU this means that the GPU is
waiting an idle waiting for commands to
be sent to it this breaks the
parallelism between the CPU and a GPU
which makes it less efficient some of
the common causes of CPU bottlenecks
include too many draw calls and this is
because with every draw call there's a
certain amount of driver overhead on the
CPU single threading can also be an
issue this is when you put too much on
one thread for example rendering thread
rendering and game simulation on the
same thread now both of these could be
improved with the Vulcan graphics API if
you remember last year at i/o we
announced Vulcan on Android devices
Vulcan is a more explicit API than
OpenGL and it's closer to what that
hardware is actually doing this means it
has less overhead per draw call you can
also do multi-threaded command buffers
of building so another problem that
could be causing a CPU bottleneck is too
many state changes and this adds to the
driver overhead the GPU can also be a
cause of slow performance GPU
bottlenecks are when the GPU is taking
too much time to render the driver can
help this by buffering commands and up
for a couple of frames but when this cue
gets full the CPU has to just wait as
with CPU bottlenecks this breaks the
parallelism between the CPU and the GPU
some of the common causes of GPU
bottlenecks are fill rate on modern
phones the resolution is very high and
if you it can be worse if you have long
fragment shaders one thing you can do is
render to a lower resolution buffer now
the problem could be high polygon count
especially we only have heard complex
geometry buffer synchronization can also
be an issue this is when the GPU has to
wait until the CPU is done writing to a
buffer that's served between the two and
also too many state changes as with CPU
too many state changes can be a problem
these Hardware state changes can cause
the hardware the graphics hardware to
flush the pipeline which introduces a
stall overheating is a common issue with
mobile devices as the temperature goes
up the system governor has a governor
that makes the frequency and voltage go
down this is called thermal throttling
as the SOC cooled the frequency of the
voltage go back up again but then this
leads to an unstable frame rates
developers should not overlook long load
times this can cause people to stop
playing their game cold loads are when
the game needs to load assets into
memory immediates of process assets for
example you may need to decompress
assets you also may need to compile
shaders this all takes time on the CPU
you might try caching to avoid
duplicating this work every time you
load battery performance is also
important this affects how long your
users can play the game
unfortunately high performance games
tend to use more battery Vulcan can also
help with this because it has it uses
the CPU less
this is important because the CPU runs
at a higher clock speed than the GPU so
it uses more power to detect issues like
this there's several tools available
unfortunately one tool may not be enough
for example if you're doing low-level
profiling you may want to see the
hardware counters like on the GPU
this requires vendors of specific tools
so the first one we'll look at its its
trace and this is from Google this trace
is a system trace viewer and it shows
threads executing on the CPU the longer
the trace the more time is being spent
executing you can use custom trace
events in your game to see how different
sections of the game take how long they
take this can also show you how much
concurrency there is within your game
one thing you can do with systrace to
see system activity relative to your
game and see potential dependencies that
could be causing things to run slow for
more information you should watch this
session that was presented earlier at
i/o and we have it recorded on the i/o
website simple perf is a GPU profiler
from google it shows the percentages of
time spent in various parts of the game
for example we can use it to find the
share where the percentage of time spent
in shared libraries and that way we can
tell where most of the time was spent we
can we can then look at say one of these
shared libraries and then see where how
much percentage of time we'll spend in
each of the functions now one caveat
with simple perf right now it's not very
easy to use it requires a certain amount
of setup and it's only command-line but
once you get the hang of it it's
actually producing some valuable
information
other profilers include the hardware
vendor profilers for example Qualcomm
has Snapdragon profiler arm read
streamline and NVIDIA has the Tegra
system profiling game engines also have
profilers for example unity and real
have built-in profilers and also there
are graphics debuggers like render doc
and google's gap it these tools can
capture api calls that can help you find
inefficiencies in the api so here's an
example of profiling the game using the
qualcomm snapdragon profiler let's see
if we can find out where the bottleneck
is it shows that cpu traces similar to
this trace and it also shows GPU traces
so on the lower part of this display
here we can see the CPU scheduling with
colors corresponding to each thread on
the upper part is the GPU activity where
the blue bars represent when the GPU is
is rendering now the first thing we'll
notice here is that the GPU is idle for
a long time that's bad
in contrast the CPU core one is busy
almost the whole time this is a classic
case of a CPU bottleneck now we might be
able to multi thread this but in this
case this is the render thread and
OpenGL you can't do multi-threaded
rendering so let's take a closer look at
what's going on by doing a frame capture
now a frame capture shows us the API
call similar to debuggers like render
doc and if we look at the frame capture
we look at the draw calls there's a lot
of draw calls going on here almost 1500
draw calls that's actually a lot for too
much for a mobile CPU i remember with
every draw call there's CPU overhead and
that all adds up
so one thing we can do is we can draw
less or we can batch these draw calls
together by the ones that have the same
materials
that's them together and we'll have
fewer draw calls which will improve
performance our next speaker is Zhang Lu
Kim and he is a principal engineer at
Samsung he will talk about aim
optimizations thank you
well I'm John Kim I'm managing GPU
driver graphics performance for Alex
product and also reading corner standard
and game dev tag in Samsung mobile
division so I will talk about what
should be the right direction of the
gaming optimization and also some best
practices from our real experiences I
think you all knows about sometimes good
phone maker but you may not know about
we are not working with many game
developer for improving Android
ecosystem in Thailand descent so we are
working with over 50 game studios and
developers where around study game
titles - with with various kind of way
under our new game developer support
program Galaxy games app from March last
year thank you Pottinger then I also
strongly appreciate my team insulin HQ
UK US and Ukraine to support partners
with endless overnight work with many
beers
during our supporting game developers we
also have question about what would be
the real goal of gaming optimization
just keeping stable frame per second
like this small mark but looks like it's
getting boring by frame by frame and
doesn't look like it will bring high
fidelity to any games like this quality
level also would be another point we
have to take care the resolutions in
complexity and more visual intensive
graphics the games will have more rich
content with better quality and this can
make games fun to play the traditional
optimization is just trade-off between
quality and performance always we want
to get more frame per second than should
expect last quality low content quality
is the reason of boring users will leave
easily even the game is still keeping 60
frames per second some graphics
potentials will give you way to manage
both quality and performance but it
works only with with some corner cases
only then how we can make this this is
even a year ago bulk and mo protest out
what we shown to you during our f7
unpack now how can we chase both quality
and performance at the same time with
more general use cases I want to show
one simple example from hardware side
because we're for maker the thermal
throttling is one of the critical
problem of phone maker like us Samsung
has a good structure of managing Salmo
from AP chipset that stuck in a certain
level in in nowadays so we optimize the
structure of a hip spreader and change
the interface metal material has the
nine times bur conductivity between heat
spreader and AV chipset so now galaxy s
have eight has seven degree wrap every
chip sasame in worst case scenario and
this gives more comfortable experiences
to user when
play games this is not just trade up but
making fundamental changes to back break
through jump then how we can do similar
thing with software side not hardware
side cheating both quality and
performance we strongly believe the
answer should be okay
Vulcan is open standard cross problem
new generation graphics API from Chronos
group it's really thin lightweight
predictable horrible and terrible its
support precise explicit control and
deliver a bunch of great tools to
optimize your games when many times face
at nothing do more situation except drop
in quality with old API GL yes OpenGL ES
is easy to use and can make quick
prototyping so it's still usable for
some use cases but we believe the Buchan
is is breakthrough jump like I show to
you is the solder example in software
side first low CPU over half book on
your thin structure so primer can has
very small overhead in CPU the over
hundred rovco's can easily spend some no
seconds with the GL yet but Vulcan
doesn't this will give you some margin
on resources and you can use it for your
own proposals like better performance or
longer battery life we implemented many
POC level broken samples to prove broken
is really good thing to our marketing
team you may not even imagine how many
samples we implemented before after
launching for convincing internal people
this is a regular MOU which one over
sample which our team developed for
around September 2015 you can see lap
sidewalk and uses similar or last CPU
but Randall's almost double or more
per second Dungey Elliot you may think
this is just demo sample or Connor Cates
but broken works with the real games -
here is a bang glory we have been
working with super backup since April
2016 you can see right side up Vulcan
shows much stable frame per second
without big frame drops we see around 20
percent performance gain near 63 percent
60 frames per second in even throttling
situation with the galaxy s7 second
xsplit control you can manage precise
command buffer submit from one of each
render pass over one for some groups of
random faces you also can change the
pendants between each pattern stage
where the pipeline barrier function if
you give barriers between fragment to
birthday stage then every birthday stage
will wait until finishing previous
fragment stage if you change barrier
between every frame stage fragment stage
then there will be no waiting between
fragment to birthday stage anymore
you also can manage the memory more
precisely you can use different memory
try for each profiles and this will give
you more optimal memory management so
this is the f5 streamline capture all
the searching again we are working with
first capture show's original GL ES and
there are wide gap between each around
the fences coming from CPU overhead of
some hundred draw holes for each render
path 12 milliseconds for GPU processing
is required even after we caught
everything with the Balkans but can see
captures number two worst performance
like 24 seconds millisecond these comes
from using wrong type mm barrier the
number three is now showing the proper
barrier and then it takes just 12
milliseconds
third a uniform uniform is one of a
critical part of graphics programming
this has a basic intention of
interaction between CPU and GPU
so you can give quite big impact to
performance in many cases but you can
manage uniform buffer in broken to get
less or better performance we develop a
four different incremental money
implementation from brute force to
either condition of dynamic offset way
and you can see the performance
differences from the one frame per
second to forty three frames per second
let's see the video clips from our 1250
draw whole sample implementation like
this
Buchan gives you ability to control
things precisely but you may also feel
is hard to handle but you don't have to
worry about the handle by yourself all
the things with the bull pendulum
intention but the game engine support
now okay
we've worked with applicants from these
2015 for the Yui for spoken supporting
they release the 412 as first Vulcan RHS
for you for and recent release broken
support is now getting better and better
we've worked with unity for supporting
working in unity 5 since September 2016
and 5.6 released recently at the first
of fishable contenders for unit version
to wrap up we believe hookah is the
answer for treating both quality and
performance to develop high fidelity
game in android from many experiences
with our patent game companies and
developers it can give more performance
wrong battery life
less heat problem more visual quality to
your game look little bit complicated
but still game engine will help you can
use it even without any understanding of
Vulcan evil notation one more thing
Vulcan will help more with mass
mainstream devices we touched it with
one of Vulcan games with both Delphia 7
and 8 5 2017 model the c-more
performance gain with the Galaxy s5 it
means flagship show better performance
but Vulcan will boost more with mass
product so Buchan is not only flagship
feature anymore
we are all ready to develop high
fidelity gaming Android devices
technologies
platforms are all set it up I want to
introduce to do about introduced of us
the religious two levels in case studies
[Applause]
okay thank you ah yeah develop Indonesia
- you're a lot in Marblehead long okay
perhaps my name is Chuck I'm a PP over
marketing intelligence in the mobile and
I'm here to introduce digital revolution
and to share Samsung in Google and then
Marco walking what kind of because we
made video last year I did a short
speech like this on random that was a
part over my bad memory so I give time
not to make that kind of thing again if
I prepared too many video clips Allah
that we will not make you bored so
before talking least I want to show you
a very short clip over Linda -
[Music]
[Applause]
yep yeah one thing I want to tell you is
you see the actual gameplay video on a
mobile device
maybe Samsung s7 maybe I think our title
could be a cold or high-performance game
by graphic quality and list but to my
boss the most important thing maybe as a
high football most means high KPI so I
want to share what kinda KPI we achieved
in Korea yep
liquid workings of death losing level
digital revolution was a huge ease of
the short 30 days after lunch
this title achieved over 176 million US
dollars only in South Korea we just
opened give title in South Korea yet it
took only 17 days to on 100 billion US
dollars and if you GTA 5 million monthly
active users this is same amount as 10
percent of South Korea population every
number selected in a South Korea mobile
game industry and it let coded to over 2
million daily active users we do our
best to keep this number because the
lytic tool evolution is an MMORPG the
best number were concurrent user is very
very important and the electrode 740,000
five weeks later after lunch if the huge
amount of people finally according to
super data research ninja tool evolution
was the number one title in global
mobile market on February only in
February just one month but we are proud
of it I said we just opened this title
only in Korea and the Korea mobile
market is not mobile not big what I want
to say is number one in Korea doesn't
means number one in global but February
we make them
to make this kind of a lizard
when it landed to develop its title we
had three major goals to make it to be
the next level title the first thing is
3-play confocal epic quality the ax we
just wanted a kind of graphics on the
porn
the second thing is best open world
environment in Korea before least
LEvolution Toby's generally was action
RPG and action RPG means every user
tried every stage for enjoying game and
that then makes many people boards so a
we thought open world will be a answer
for them and their status is merciful
captivate city kappa cheese is very
important why that is important is to
expand our Tyrell lifespan making new
content is not enough it takes too much
time
if it's too much money so are to extend
our lifespan the most important thing is
making usual build their community based
on our content that content is catechist
I want to show you two clips one clip is
introduction clip and the other is
actual gameplay video
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
yes this is the introduction video over
carefully the mode the one thing I want
to tell you is to enjoy it if this kind
of a good content every user have to
make build their own plan and help to
discuss about how to win how to beat the
others then that means to enjoy this one
people the users has to make us on their
own community so this is actual play
video
[Music]
x2 slightly
okay yep it's also you can enjoy this
kind of content on your mobile phone the
all-time battle wages up to 250 hours
but that is not easy there are so many
problems we have to solve something like
the stable flame light and the thermal
problem and the battery performance as
we said earlier so how to make it a
concern we thought or complain via one
of our solution so we expect it to be
the Balcombe we can solve the flame rate
problem and also our Barre problems so
this actual example the outside user
using Burcham the downside is reserved
to using our opengl you can check the
frame rate the per conversion rules are
both stable this is another example
and because of frame rate is more stable
we can add more effects this is the
original version of a lunatic tool
evolution this is are using our open gel
you can see very clear screen and we as
they're so cute effects that makes her
usual feel the depth of the environment
so we just get started and we have to
improve our graphics to maintain our
position in Korea and we've learnt to
launching give titles at Korea and the
you can enjoy dictated active content
baby I Indy fear that means we have to
make our title on well on low and device
without keeping our edge and the week we
believe we can do that video welcome
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]